♪
>> EVERY MONTH I COME HERE AND I
HEAR THE SAME THING,
SOCIAL-EMOTIONAL HEALTH.
IF YOU TRULY MEAN THAT, YOU
WOULD END THE MASK REQUIREMENT
TONIGHT.
THIS IS NOT MARCH 20 ANYMORE,
AND IT’S TIME.
TAKE THESE MASKS OFF OF MY
CHILD.
AINSLEY: THAT GEORGIA MOTHER IS
GOING VIRAL AFTER TAKING A STAND
FOR STUDENTS AND HER CHILD IF
DEMANDING HER COUNTY SCHOOL
BOARD REMOVE THE MASK MANDATE.
THIS IS DOWN IN GEORGIA.
OUR NEXT GUEST WHO’S BEEN
PRESSING THE CDC FOR ANSWERS ON
WHY THEY ARE STILL REQUIRING
CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS 2 TO WEAR
MASKS.
HERE NOW IS SENATOR MIKE LEE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: YOU COULD HEAR THE
LADY’S FRUSTRATION.
SHE STOOD UP THERE AND SAID MY
CHILD AND OTHER CHILDREN IN OUR
DISTRICT BEGGING PARENTS TO COME
TO THESE SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS,
TELL THEM, PLEASE, THESE KIDS
DON’T WANT TO WEAR MASKS IN
SCHOOL.
AND TELL US ABOUT THE LETTER
THAT YOU SENT.
>> YEAH.
RECENTLY I SENT A LETTER TO
DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY, DIRECTOR
OF THE CDC, ASKING WHY THIS IS
THE CASE, WHY IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA WE HAVE THESE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS IN PLACE
DIRECTING PEOPLE TO PUT MASKS ON
CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS 2 YEARS
OLD
WHEN OUR PEER NATIONS ALL OVER
THE WORLD HAVE SET IT MUCH, MUCH
HIGHER.
LOOK, OUR ALLIES, OUR PEER
NATIONS ALL OVER EUROPE FROM THE
U.K., FROM FRANCE, IN SO MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE THE AGE UP
AT AROUND 11 OR 12.
EVEN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THAT’S MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE SAYS MAYBE 5 AND UP.
BUT IT’S AT 2 AND UP IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT REFLECTS SOME REAL HUBRIS.
IT REFLECTS REALLY WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SOMEBODY ISSUING THE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS DOESN’T SPEND
A LOT OF TIME WITH 2-YEAR-OLDS.
BUT AS MUCH AS ANYTHING, WE JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE IS.
LOOK, WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN OF
THAT AGE HAVE A LOWER RATE OF
INFECTION.
WE HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY HAVE A TENDENCY TO SPREAD
THE VIRUS LESS.
IS SO I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IS IF WE
NEED TO HAVE CHILDREN AS YOUNG
WITH AS 2 BEING FORCED TO WEAR A
MASK.
AINSLEY: THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER, WE’VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT COVID, ALSO TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER OBTAINED
THIS MEMO FROM POLITICO.
POLITICOS HAD SEND THIS MEMO OUT
TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRATION AND
SAID DO NOT CALL IT A CRISIS IS.
AVOID REFERRING TO THE PRESENT
SITUATION AS A CRISIS.
ALTHOUGH WE MAY QUOTE OTHERS
USING THAT LANGUAGE WHILE
PROVIDING CONTEXT, WHILE THE
SHARP INCREASE IS A PROBLEM FOR
BORDER OFFICIALS, A POLITICAL
CHALLENGE FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND A DIRE
SITUATION FOR MANY MIGRANTS WHO
MAKE THE JOURNEY, IT DOES NOT
FIT THE DICTIONARY DEFINITION OF
A CRISIS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> IF THEY THINK THAT THIS ISN’T
A CRISIS, THEY NEED TO SELECT A
NEW DICTIONARY.
IF THEIR DICTIONARY SOMEHOW ON
SOME BIZARRE PLANET DOESN’T
MATCH THIS, MAYBE THEY HAVEN’T
BEEN TO THE BORDER, AND THEY’RE
LOOKING FOR THE WRONG
DEFINITION.
LOOK, THE FACT IS ANYONE WHO’S
BEEN DOWN THERE, AS I HAVE IN
RECENT WEEKS, AS SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE, IT IS NOTHING
SHORT OF A CRISIS.
LOOK, WE WERE DOWN THERE, WE
LITERALLY SAW A HUMAN BODY
FLOATING IN THE RIO GRANDE.
WE LITERALLY SAW WOMEN AND
INFANT CHILDREN SLEEPING IN THE
DIRT, AND WE SAW 4200 CHILDREN
CRAMMED INTO A FACILITY
CURRENTLY DESIGNED TO HANDLE NO
MORE THAN 250.
IF THAT’S NOT A CRISIS, I DON’T
KNOW WHAT IS.
THE HUMAN SUFFERING HERE IS
BEYOND A SCALE THAT MOST
AMERICANS SEE ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
SO THE REAL QUESTION IS WHY ARE
THEY JUST DECIDING TO DO FAVORS
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BIRDIES TORTING THE TRUTH? -- BY
DISTORTING THE TRUTH?
AINSLEY: ECONOMIC CRISIS, POLICE
BRUTAL CITY, THE CLIMATE IS A
CRISIS BUT APPARENTLY NOT
IMMIGRATION.
SENATOR LEE, THANK YOU SO MUCH